one of the Campeche thank you for having
me yeah I I wrote a letter I was like
can we get chairs and table that fits me
please I mean how like your knees aren't
even touching the table no I have like
lots of rooms like it might come so
comfortable I have a surprise for you
you're my dessert queen and we're
camping so we have s'mores Cheers
are you a s'mores fan I am were you a
camper growing up like did you go to
summer camp I did I went to a bunch of
different camps growing up I went to a
horse camp I went to an archery camp I
went to a soccer camp different sports
camps they were usually just like day
camp yeah you go for Dave no weird
wilderness bill how much fun is it to
like hang out with all your friends and
I know you guys like talked offline as
well it's amazing it's fun right because
we're all so busy yeah and I think it's
a good thing because we have all so many
different like cool things going on but
this is the one time of year where
you'll get to see everyone you'll run
into each other everywhere every Hall
panels after parties and it just kind of
feels like a little reunion like you get
a check in with everyone then maybe you
haven't seen in a little while we talk
about hug like cute and clean your
s'more is in mine is just like going to
ask you what is going on together
supposed to like hold to the bottom when
I took a bite everybody's way that's
fine it is summer camp at et what is
your favorite summer memory like what
you think of summer like oh you got it
it's right here but one of my favorite
is water fights yeah water balloons yes
we're good what did you do in summertime
we were like running through the
sprinklers we would make our own slip
and slide get to-- yeah we made a slip
later he did like black trash trash bags
like those guards would be efficient
what are your summer treats right now
this summer
popsicles man you just got back from
really fun trip we talked about that for
a second notice came back from France
you guys and I just got to film a baking
video in Julia Child's former cottage
get out of Julia Child she's my favorite
chef right she inspired me to start not
only cooking and like but
trying things new in the kitchen her
cottage they named it luffy tune which
in french means the little one because
it's a very small little cottage come on
oh one that is serendipity right there
was that too perfect certified the stars
aligned that day that week you're gonna
do a video on there right yeah video
comes out next week and i made two
dishes from her cookbook mastering the
Art of French Cooking vol 2 and she
actually wrote that book while she was
living at the cottage that's awesome
thank you for hanging out with us come
back next summer we're gonna cook but
I'm so excited I can't wait to watch
those videos should we cheers one last
time